okay now I expect you're probably still
drawing at the moment I where possible
and I advise you know within a surface
area and volume topic we really should
be up to this now bring a ruler and use
it when you are constructing a diagram
like this it's not necessary I didn't
use a ruler for this but that's partly
because this diagram is the size of my
face said it's a lot easier to make a
neat diagram when it's enormous if
you're drawing a smaller one
precision matters a lot more straight
lines will help you draw a diagram that
is more helpful to you that's the point
it's not that we have a fixation our
rulers we just want to help you make
better diagram now as you're going I
want you to notice what I have done the
first step was let's just reproduce what
they've got let's just do that draw it
all with all the measurements on and as
I do that I get a better understanding
of how the shape fits together then
secondly and I've done this in another
column because the more colors I have in
a meaningful way they're less busy my
diagram would be can you see what I've
put in blue there what am i doing which
principle am I using here this is the
second force what I'm naming I'm
labeling those faces so I can talk about
okay now just put your pins down for a
second I will give you time to finish
but I want you to look at the next step
math to do because it's a bit unusual
this kind of shape which is sort of
rectangular in a lot of ways even though
the whole thing is all shape this shape
is quite common okay so therefore I'm
going to give you a bit of a tip for
this one which is useful and these
particular kinds of shapes not useful
all the time no use for for these but
you'll see is so often it's worth
knowing the specifics here have a look
do you see I've labeled three of the
faces okay bottom the front and this
right hand side one
how many faces are left too late count
carefully so it looks to me like I
haven't done the back I haven't done the
back I haven't done so this one I
haven't done this sign face this face
this face or this face
do you agree that mechanic's so far how
does that look fine what do you think
yeah okay now the reason why I have it
we can go through this one at a time the
first face I mentioned that I haven't
labeled is the back give me a suggestion
as to why I have not labeled the back
right very good if I work at the front I
just need to double it and I've got it I
didn't take you front back different
names it's the same thing the less names
I have the better to be honest
so all name what I absolutely have to
then going forward have a look for
example at the faces that are looking
upwards that's this one in this one okay
now they currently position quite far
apart to imagine in your mind's eye I
want you to imagine taking this not
changing its size by just moving it up
here translating it is the fancy way
views if those two upward faces were
next to each other
what would they become they become the
bottom face when they were they'd become
the same size with the bottom face do
you agree so therefore rather than
giving them independent
which is confusing I'm gonna call this
one top one and top two so I know
actually you know what when they go
together there'll be the same as the
bottom there are really two parts of the
same thing
do you see where I'm gonna go next why I
didn't meant right in the left faces
because again you play the same trick
this guy here the really tall medical
one if you move him over he's gonna
confined with this guy and be together
the same is the right are you with me
so therefore I'm gonna call this left
one and left
okay now I'm ready I look I'll let you
get a bit of a head start on me right my
first slide down and then you see where
you would take it from there I will say
surface area equals okay and I'm gonna
name all my faces every single one all
added together and then I'll start to
actually substitute values so I've got
let's see
[Music]
okay that's the hit stop I'm gonna give
you I think you will do really well and
we'll solve this as efficiently as
possible if you start with this I'll let
you get a head start and work out those
numbers okay I want you to just have a
look at this work if you didn't get it
or got something but you just read with
maybe you want to come and eat and grab
a picture as you're backing out there
are two final things I want to know you
have to make a competent face here like
even this face is focusing you can do it
by addition or subtraction I did a bio
t-shirt while seem like when you're
honest play the card just watch out
where you've got faces that are in
contact with one another see this circle
here on the bottom of the hemisphere and
on the top the comb do you include that
no but why not it's not part of the
surface right so just watch out for that
in your corner